l'argent un sujet vaste qui peut faire
peur mais pourtant essentiel à la
réussite d'une entreprise et thématique
principale de la 7e édition des
rencontres
kreactive calculer son prix et défendre
ses marges
optimiser ses revenus et sa fiscalité
partenaires et chefs d'entreprise ont
évoqué l'argent sous tous ses angles le
temps d'une après midi avec un objectif
aider les porteurs de projets qu'il soit
féminin au masculin
donc ça me permet de vraiment complété
de bien maîtriser le sujet faut être sûr
qu'à devant un client je puisse vraiment
définir mais bon prix les marches qu'il
faut et ainsi de suite pour pouvoir
fonctionner sur aws et aux hommes par
exemple nos valeurs voilà c'est une
thématique qui me parlait donc je
voulais je voulais y participer fort
d'un réseau de 130 femmes chefs
d'entreprise et porteuses de projets
huit tables rondes étaient prévus pour
ces rencontres
kreactive des rencontres ouvertes aussi
aux curieux en 2016 plus de 550 mille
entreprises ont été créées en france on
a quand même l'idée que
l'entrepreneuriat aujourd'hui c'est
possible pour tous les gens plus d'idées
et ils ont envie de se lancer donc
l'objet aussi de ces rencontres c'est de
leur donner des clés pour essayer ces
personnes secret se lancer c'est y
tester pied bain l'association leur
permet d'échanger aussi beaucoup pour
répondre à la demande grandissante sur
le territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines créactive organise chaque mois
plusieurs événements le prochain est
prévu lundi 4 décembre pour informer sur
les risques et les opportunités à
l'international